we have really good film talks we go off
and talking about all kinds of films
from Cinema Paradiso to anything right
we talk about characters talk about
these actors
I am a massive David leaving fan
[Music]
so that's Lawrence of Arabia so check
the desert box obviously
we've got a fetish for deserts you have
to actually do a horse Chase in the
Jordanian desert in Akbar where they
shot Lawrence Moravia
Justin be there to see Lawrence fish can
blow out a match like Puro tool is worth
all the pain and suffering of directing
for the last 10 years for sure
Chad makes references that I get he'll
talk to me about a movie he'll say oh
I'm a little bit of this and that a
little bit from this movie a little bit
from that movie I'll be like oh yes I
get it chatterson I guess it's in a file
between King County they're pretty much
a library a repository of films 70s 60s
70s into the 80s
challenge is really drawn to The Good
The Bad and The Ugly
[Music]
magenta single combat sort of iconic
fight was something that we all pictured
and thought would be so incredible to
modernize and use Paris as the backdrop
and I think the channel wanted to sort
of tap into John with being a western
and John Wick as a western character
[Music]
Samurai films
western eastern mixing together
so unique and then also perfect matching
for the John Wick world